how do you guys know each other where
we all just accept that as a thing none
of us know what it means what does it
mean
see how quiet them anti-vaxxas audience
got they don't trust you three people
clapped and the rest of this Republican
episode he was like get this
you put microchips in US ain't that
crazy you saved the world and the
internet made everybody think you're
killing us all which company
you ain't make no vaccine nobody heard
of you ever walked through Walmart and
you look at a high sense TV and you're
like what the is Hisense who else
has a job that Tick Tock made us hate
because of the internet we respect them
not at all and so we're like hey give
them their props hey sex workers come on
show them some respect they're not
criminals like scientists